hey what is up everybody Anna Mack here
for anime up or welcome to Ranke fame
which is our weekly live stream here on
the channel every Thursday 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time where we discuss
various anime topics we debate we go
crazy but this is a very special one
because type thank you know I had the
idea to ask you guys to come up with
your ideas for a minor academia
character and then what we did was look
at all the submissions which we got like
if you look at all the different
platforms at least a thousand
submissions we got which is damn nuts I
did not expect that at all your close
so what we did was pick I was extremely
helpful by the way just letting you know
it totally wasn't only animatic that did
everything no I told him listen like
that 16 of our favorites and then we're
going to do like a tournament art here
during this live stream and decide the
winner
alive as we go we will tell you who the
sixteen are because there's no pictures
for them most of them so you couldn't do
like a bracket but you can listen along
and yeah I mean I'm really really
impressed by the response and all the
creative ideas it was awesome guys thank
you so much I am so blown away that
we're definitely gonna do contests like
this in the future both for MHA and
other animes because I you know you guys
loved it you want to be a part of it so
we want to definitely make more in the
future for example what do you guys
think about design and attack on Titan
character and how he gets eaten that's
how to get eaten scenario yeah so yeah
this is gonna be a really interesting
stream thank you again for everyone who
participated so yeah over like a
thousand submissions crazy stuff we pick
our favorites based on which characters
we think would be the most interesting
in the actual anime let's say to
introduce them which characters we would
like the most but obviously that's our
opinion that's how these contests go but
a lot of creative ideas a lot of ideas
that we couldn't include I wanted to so
that's why we are going to have future
Thanks thanks to every single person who
submitted really appreciate that and
yeah if you're in the top 16 you're
already in like the top two percent so
you're already a huge winner and yeah
Congrats guys Congrats adamak I can't
believe you read through a thousand
that's unreal I feel bad not Stephen
contributed more than me he rather he'd
been the thumbnail yeah
thankfully guys we had you know a word
limit which some people did not at all
pay attention to but the people that did
that there's the word limit we read them
and yeah yeah one thing I read a few of
them and some of them were not exactly
the word limit there was one that was
some guy I don't even remember his quirk
but the description was he is badass
don't go overboard here know the name
our rule one was the best one ever
how did that win because what we're
gonna do is we're gonna talk about you
know serious submissions however before
we decide the finals I will give you my
three top meme submissions and then we
will decide which means submission is
going to be the best meme submission and
the reward for that will be glory and
nothing else but whatever will have
their hero brought to life by a
professional artist Cuusoo money by the
way his info is in the description as
well as NOx and Briggs's stuff so check
them out for sure
and yeah so anything you guys want to
say before we get started yeah the best
meme submission was knucks cactus and
the second best who has the Lord Twigg
oh we will see there were some really
good ones the name are rollin with
hilarious man it could dodge any attack
no our only thing I want to say there
were a lot of like quirks that I noticed
they were like kind of similar like for
example shadow manipulation was very
popular you tomorrow using all
manipulate all the elements like the
avatar was extremely popular animal
abilities so we had to basically choose
whichever character overall we felt
would be the best so if you you know
that's just the way it is if there's
similar quirks
we got a look at other stuff but yeah
there were a lot of similarities between
certain entries so kind of disappointed
there were no quirks that turn you into
Mineta but aside from that we're all
good
hey you're assuming that you don't know
well out of the few that I've read
another thing is we had a summon you
know entries that were like so old peds
guys would like one shot Asano's so that
was interesting but yeah like we try not
to go to Opie try not to go with
characters have the exact same quirks as
existing characters in the actual series
but otherwise we were very open-minded
so yeah I'm excited are you guys ready
for the first round yes y'all ready for
this all right
sound typed let's get into the first
round so the first two heroes that will
be going head-to-head and I try to
combine these pairings in terms of some
similarities of the heroes real style
yes we have the dark hero nightshade
submitted by @kk to jingle vs. phantom
submitted by mario craft 6000 let me now
get to the descriptions of all of these
and okay so for the dark here of
nightshade his quirk is shadow form
actually her quirk because it says she
can morph into and coat her body in
shadows I like it better already
yes she's avoided because of her dark
eerie power which fits more of a villain
type character but despite this she
wants to be a hero and she looks up to
people like Aizawa
who fit who fight without needing a
super strong battle quirk so interesting
like a rosary of Shinzo in the way that
he has occurred that people think is
more suited for a villain but he still
wants to be a hero so very cool and the
other one let me just find it near
phantom hero named phantom quirk shadow
arms when he was four years old
all-4-one who killed this character's
parents and gave him a quirk which
combined with his own quirk
and fused into a quark that allowed him
to shoot shadow like arms from anywhere
on his body like mental gifts I like
this quote because it reminds me of
elfin lead or battle goose okay yes but
but which is actual shadow arms you
ripped off all else and legal will make
believe all right so guys which one do
you prefer I'm going with shadow bimbo I
don't remember her name please no sexist
okay you know what she is a lovely young
lady saddle female who's a very
independent woman a strong independent
woman by the way what's her quick
exactly like you said it like her
shadows to cover her body she can morph
into and quote her body in shadows so
how we got pretty dope how would that
benefit you in a battle well it's not
necessarily for combat it could be for
gathering intelligence it could be I
don't know I can imagine a whole bunch
of thing uses aside from brute force I
guess like in like at night it'd be
super like hard to see her if you like
becomes a shadow right yeah but with
some of these if you know we have only
limited information that you'll provide
it so we can I guess extrapolate certain
things but it's so you know if we can
talk about it debated what do we think
the power actually does well yeah I
think that that would be a very cool
thing if you can like become a shadow
essentially and move like a shadow who
feel like it could even be like you can
move like kinda like fast like a shadow
as well and I kind of end up behind
someone and then morph back into your
whom human self to attack that would
cool kind of like rogue from fairy tale
not that any of you have watched fairy
tale but he can like dive into his
shadow and just become a shadow that
glides along the floor I don't know I
think that's really cool even though
that was my thinking yeah I think that's
that's what this is getting at which is
what I really like about it and Arturo
nightshade
yeah so and phantom has basically shadow
arms and you can shoot out of his body
and I assume they could just rip people
apart and [ __ ] metal gear style yes yes
elfin wheat dough for me anybody else
I'm trying to think we wanna vote for
how they go with the fee
darkhero nightshade and I think I am
also leading for dark your nitrogens
because I think that power of becoming a
shadow it's yourself is really cool but
you'd respect the phantom as well so
dark hero nightshade moves on to the
second round the next matchup we have
Sat oil mill known but submitted by
means senpai in French by the way so I'm
gonna have to be translating this versus
the Flor floral hero IV submitted by
Kayla mcLaughlin mcLaughlin nothing is
wrong with shadow bimbo knocks don't
worry okay so sartorial his career perk
is the ability to change the state of
any nonliving object into either solid
liquid or gas so the three different
states heads nope yeah she does not have
a hero costume yet because get this
midnight sensei has refused all my
stupid proposals and Aizawa sensei has
deprived me of my costume as long as I
do not pay more attention in class I
really like how this is like in her
family she was the only one that didn't
have a cord that gives her exceptional
intellectual abilities and for this
reason she felt worthless and inferior
especially compared to her little sister
who is a genius of her generation but
then one day her family was caught in a
fire and she was able to save her sister
thanks to her quirk because she could
change the fire into another element and
because of this she realized that as a
hero she could be useful sold or she
doesn't want to necessarily be the next
number-one hero like all Mike she wants
to help people rescue them reassure them
and wants to know that people can count
on her and also wants to start her own
clothing brand personality on this way I
hope I didn't miss translate but I'm
wondering like if she could turn things
from Ella from different states of
matter to other states of matter if she
turns fire what she turning fire into
solid that would be terrible
to us to think about you know what that
would look like she runs with her gun
and she's people with like turned into
ice before it hits them ice shards so
that's cool
that's really cool or turning water into
ice to skate on it but if but if or if
some big mass like a solid gets thrown
at her or whatever she could turn it
into a liquid or yes no it's like what
do you turn fire into water okay and
then everyone drowns
oh that's okay could she turn any
element like into anything literally
anything or does she just changed like
the state of it from what I ended it was
date of it the state of it okay I'm one
of the three states yeah so I question
the credibility in her backstory but I
like the hero okay I think I think
what's cool about this cork is a lot of
people talked about manipulating all the
elements like the avatar but I feel like
that is really old pee whereas this one
it's like specific you have to touch an
object to actually change its state but
you can you know do anything you want
with it so it's it's an obviously
awesome quirk but still limited she has
to touch the fire so like every time to
me was a change it the burn yourself
yeah oh yeah by the way yeah I think in
the story since she's got some burns
from saving her sister - and the second
one is again the floral hero IV real
name Hana Yukimura Herbert's name is
nature's call nature's call and
basically she from what I've read she
can control nature like my plants and
stuff but you can't create them so she
can control existing nature mm-hmm but
she can't create new so for example she
carries like some roots and stuff on her
wrists tied around her wrists so she can
then use them control the plants in
battle has had so it's like really cool
curve you make slowly
Kurama from from YuYu Hakusho sure sure
Briggs helped again a cool quirk that is
still limited like so if you're in the
city you're like you better like use
like a plan from like up someone's
balcony you can't use like a anyway
could you use grass as little needle
missiles cuz that would be beast yeah
but what they hurt hell yeah
oh maybe maybe her father is a hero
which is one of the reason she wants to
become one but her she little sister was
murdered by a villain and that's her
main driving force in life yeah so she's
one of those Justice seekers mm-hmm yeah
so I actually like both they're both
cool I vote for SATA you minyan because
I think this changing state into matter
thing it's not something I've really
seen before
so originality points aside from a sick
backstory story a personality and I like
it I vote for that one
Thank You arcs bricks man these are both
pretty good and it took me a second to
realize while you're talking about
knucks what's Kurama like his vine whip
shitty thing yeah I think this quirk has
a lot more potential than Kurama Kurama
had some like next-level hopi abilities
later on but even right from the start
he had those things that suck out your
energy and whatever yeah yeah hmm I'm
gonna go with a state girl as well it's
more potential for like good writing
there we go
victory to this state girl the state
girl all right that would actually be my
board as well what a close call really
like both of these again creative quirks
that are limited but really would be
interesting in the show so we have sat
to your media known making it to the
second round tipping the hat to the
floor of hero ID next around
we have Coke on Takada aka magic maidens
submitted by at CFG six four five six
three eight two six a lot of numbers
Yoanna mag did you only pick girls no
okay
versus the lotto @gl hanson 98 so co
kentucky DA has the ability called
substitution ability to trade places or
position with anyone within a certain
range or radius
Sasuke is Rinnegan power can swap two to
five people with each other including
her
self can only be used two times in a day
hmm limitation yeah okay I like that
idea it's not like just random teleports
like Haas do you have to switch places
which again I feel like would be cool in
an actual anime also there's uh there's
a limitation to it as far as twice a day
it can't just be like back and forth and
make them basically invincible and also
within a certain radius it's not like oh
I would like to go to London today
exactly you had to be with a person and
object can be with anything I assume
people okay oh no about a thing like I
think I have a lot more potential it
wasn't just with people you know well
then it's just like the substitution
jutsu from Naruto and it's just exactly
I don't know just what the person is
kind of like oh well that's a skates big
endgame move right swapping people
around does Rinnegan like it still like
it still be by powerful I guess like
someone you're just like an enemy [ __ ]
Madra as a belt attack your breath
someone and use like swap it out for
like mana is like partner or something
or you could swap yourself with Madara
oh yeah or it with mother's partner it
technically says anyone it doesn't say
anything I'm guessing we're gonna use
just right or has you in a headlock or
like seven of these things reference and
then boom you're you have him in a
headlock swap places with each other yes
yeah is trickster thing yeah like that's
what I thought it was they got school
like all yourself get rekt to swap with
the person that's a we understand that
it's a cool hero okay but we have to go
also talk about its rival model whose
quirk is randomizer lotto has been
mistress ever since it squirt developed
by touching someone's forehead he can
scramble the genetic code that
determines their quirk and temporarily
give them a random quirk or change their
quirk around so use this to mess with
teachers for example they like fumble
around they're like what's happening
they have a different quirk all of a
sudden or her work has been modified in
a way they can't control it and his dad
doesn't like him using his
this way so he walked out on him and
this leaves him to look after his mother
was sick and five-year-old sister but he
doesn't let that get him down and he's
constantly smiling and joking around
that's an interesting one also yeah you
said he has to touch their forehead yes
toy works on touch well I loved the
possibilities like having that in an
anime where like he can mess with anyone
by like screwing up their quirk for
temporarily nobody has any random her
head is the only randomized yeah they
control it I don't think hence lotto
it's a lottery I mean yeah the quartic
is called randomizer and Lauda was the
hero name but that would be kind of the
fun you touch someone and then you see
like her do they start all something and
they become a cactus yes it would
definitely be a gag character you'd
definitely be a gag character I wouldn't
see much potential in battle with it
like it yeah so would like begin to
touch the guy's forehead look if you
have a knife this quirk is useless in
battle you just a guy in the head
instead and that's eating way more
effective way about it and all of a
sudden instead of like having spores
just like the cactus
he's just farting everywhere yeah and
then you pops up what did they become a
monster like way stronger than they
originally were somebody becomes like
all my yeah well it could be do it to
himself though uh I guess just hold his
hand out keep tapping himself waiting
for something to come out some explorer
that'd be really cool if he keeps on
randomizing how long's it lasted to see
how much how long it lasts it says okay
what I'm guessing I'm guessing it would
still be good you know for like a battle
yeah that's a like that's at like 15
minutes 20 minutes right he could before
he goes into a fight keep on randomize
until you get something Oh Pete that's
pretty good
yeah but I don't know if he'd do it to
himself it's not it doesn't seem that
way but you feel either for the touch
someone's forehead right well yeah so
could be himself I mean but most of
these people they don't really work on
themselves yeah
most
them like I mean like there we go but
mean Atticus like he repels off of his
balls it's all they're just not there
just bouncy instead of sticky I mean yes
this is a good one
I vote magic maiden because this witchy
around II thing has a lot of possibility
to give a really exciting fight you know
to make a really interesting fight
happen I can see these used in so many
situations that you just don't see
coming
I'm gonna vote for the lottery guy
because I love getting characters guy
here just make sure so much better for
me and let you know you know what like I
said I do like the Magic Man but I also
think I'm gonna vote for a lot oh I just
love like I said my main criteria is
what I want to see this character in the
anime and I would love to see a
character that can mess with all your
favorite characters like for example he
messes with me at the end I mean if
those balls become cactus balls yeah
think about it I think I think I think
the meeting one has more potential and
like in a fight for sure by if like for
some reason I think that would be
hilarious that character yeah me too so
I gotta go with Lotto and lotto is
making it to it next round two to one
but again respect to the magic maiden
and her switcheroo abilities which would
be very cool as well are you guys ready
for the next one yeah we have Dixie
normous sick name the anime dude of
course it was the anime dude oh he made
one I mean him one like garden to the
left but it was so funny and cool that I
had to include it even though I was like
damn you damn you let me just get a
couple one of his was so funny yes so
Dixie normous clerk made a hero named
insomniac quirk physical strength and
ability and ability increases depending
on how sleep-deprived he is he loves me
more than anything but he hate any hates
his quirk it has the potential to be
powerful but when his body is at its
physical peak his mind is far
so he was convinced by those around him
to become a hero when they told him
about the monetary potential involved
with the profession he only seems to do
four hours on most nights and he looks
forward to retirement more than anything
you just like this guy he's like alright
well played Dixie normous what's the
next one oh this one is amazing as well
Jack Hennessy submitted by at Jason's
are zero three three three one seven one
three one seven one three
let me find Jack yes his the name was
quark is drunkard drunkard spirit his
quark is activated what once someone is
within four meters near him and once
that happens it allows him to intoxicate
any person equal to his own level of
intoxication oh that's amazing I know I
know the only solid eyes downside is
that he also has to be drunk in order to
activate his quark because of this he
has mastered the drunken fist in order
to get actively fight sign that one
coming yeah a little to say if he they
started making first yeah so this is why
we have more backstory he he was
worthless
II thought he was worklists he worked in
his father's bar while working there he
discovered his work at the age of 15
when he accidentally acted as Kirk when
secretly having a shot of vodka
and noticing that his father showed
early symptoms of a drug despite not
having a single drop of alcohol there
yeah like most kids his age you decide
to become a hero in the hopes of using
his future fame and status to promote
his father's bar and make it more widely
known or because of how his clerk is
activating he had to go somewhere where
drinking laws were less straight
such as I don't know name a place I mean
drinking laws in Japan are very strict
that is hilarious though it's like you
have to be drunk but you can obviously
build up your tolerance everybody like
400 pounds just drunk as you are they're
like what
it's like no it's as drunk as his not as
much alcohol as well as drunkest years
true other safety they they consume the
same amount like percentage-wise like
you like 400-pound consumes like tripled
like the normal amount and then he
walked into a place to play and the guy
just died on the spot liver failure
definitely like both great entries oh I
have another question about this one if
he gets high does everyone around him
get high alsa we're just talking about
drunk okay and also for the purposes of
this stream this character is at this
time the legal drinking age whatever
that is in your country rock guy Jack
Hennessy sorry Dixie normous I want to
hear Dixie known with his description
again he it's a lair he the stronger the
less sleepy as more tired he is the more
he the stronger he becomes
blood physically a bit he loves sleeping
so he hates ask work he's a hero for
money but he hates he just wants retire
I feel like it's like a similar
situation to the last one I think the
anime dudes is funnier well Jack
Hennessy or whatever the person's name
was has a lot of potential for the
series the thing is technically Dixie
normous is basically the same as
sato-san that's his guide the guy who
eats sweets you know the guy who eats
sweets and gets stronger in here
academia one of the oh yeah one a
students it's the same basic principle
the more heat the more sweets he eats
the more mindless he gets and the
stronger he gets just like this guy the
less he sleeps the more mindless he gets
in the stronger he gets
I love seeing drunken fifth animated
Rimmer Rock Lee Rock Lee versus kimimaro
was sick and it was also in fairytale
the grand magic games but no one watch
that guy yes is from the manga but I
read the manga I don't remember who
they're talking oh yeah yeah right I'm
gonna do drunken fest dude Oh
drunken fist dude wins they're saying
from the oral art but I don't remember
no it's I think the the chants a bit
behind
I think it's lagging Oh as long it's not
the drunk guy because I think drunk guys
going all the way boys
oh yeah go drunk guy my vote Anna Mac
hungry the next ones or you want to give
a pitiful vote to the anime dude well I
mean I love both but like people are
being like saying someone is in the arc
anyway maybe it was for another round I
don't know so I'm just gonna let see how
let's go with Jack Hennessy - respect -
anime dude though this was a great
matchup I thought both of them went well
together yeah this is great the animator
you just commented I vote drunken fist
did yeah that I guess I cannot okay I
don't feel bad then another ID yeah I
guess Anna Mac likes picking iris cuz
he's a fan of oni chichi yeah we have
uma co i tak serpent hero Medusa
submitted by Rihanna at dawning serenity
vs. on submitted by at Kyle silk
let me read out these descriptions for
you ladies I'm on not based off Maggie
I heard hum on almost am poem from
judges I think that all was called or
read quick call yeah that's how I'm on
cuz that means lightning or something or
thunder something like that Michael is
the serpent here imma do so and her
quirk has the ability the abilities of a
snake along with her being able to turn
anyone she looks at into stone he animal
he turned snakes in her hair into stone
to use them for arm I'm assuming that
because the hair in her this makes in
her hair can be turned into stone that
that can be turned back and that also
her victims that she turns into stone
can also be turned back if they can
never return bag and that's a mess but
we got a look at a backstory
she was born in Portugal not in Japan
and she moved in when she was five years
old during preschool her quirk
manifested and she accidentally turned
some school children into stone this
made people uneasy around her and she
vowed to never use her eyes to turn
other
to stone so she now wears special
glasses to prevent this from happening
the event made her nervous and
anti-social sounds like she can't undo
it by the way but she still wanted to
help save others so she can prove that
her Kirk doesn't have to hurt others
so she entered UA with just her snake
her first youth stoning her snakes in
her hair part of a cleric and not others
and is studying to be a hero she is
still afraid of using her quirk on
others but again if she has snakes in
her hair and she can turn them into
stone in order to use them as weapons
that has to be temporarily no because
she could grow more snake hairs I don't
know I think that yeah like I killed a
bunch of kids no but even if she three
kids at the storm done later they turned
back that's still a little traumatized
so she doesn't have to kill the kids so
I say it's a pretty damn opie core yet
if I think it's cool also because it's
based on the historical Medusa and I'll
tell you that's why you like this it
develops her character because it's like
she doesn't want to hurt people but she
can't control it so it's like I think
it's cool but all-4-one comes and he
just looks at him and he's stone yeah
like everything boa Hancock I should
have entered a character like her she's
so hot that people turn to stone if you
get an erection you turn into stone it's
a one-piece character dawn his work is
to send people into an extreme state of
fear and terror by placing his hand on
their head he is an antihero and he
punishes people that have done wrong in
the past by traumatizing them as a form
of vengeance for their misdeeds I love
this guy
I vote am on best interrogator of all
time sorry
yeah torturing people yeah because he's
like an antihero type vigilante dude he
wouldn't mind using that whereas like a
cop couldn't also just gonna say this I
way prefer an antihero to a regular hero
I mean they can both be cool that's why
I think it's the cool matchup one of
them can incite fear and others another
one can turn people to stone but doesn't
want to and that shapes their character
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with you Michael
the serpent hero Medusa but but I like
almond as well
Oh your opinion doesn't matter cuz I win
with Emma I'm sorry yeah
modred sorry are you really not really
not really
are you really no I'm on for sure but I
don't feel bad what do I like Medusa -
like I like anything that draws off him
it doesn't hurt you bastard by the end
of the day at LP do okay I mean it
depends like so you imagine
Aizawa but whatever he looks at becomes
stone Maura laughs right
I mean and alone pretty I don't know
that's like anti-heroes
yeah anti-heroes and like what type of
like trauma or terror like who would
like to think of something like he puts
his hand on their heads and they just
start shrieking yelling and blathering
it up nor I'm just wondering if they
like he gets like your own past like
traumas and plays him to you or like he
manifests like new ones I know what a
find out all right him a thorough
alright alright by the way yes so people
are point on the one minor character in
one of the manga arcs has a similar
quirk where he he's a drunk and he
affects the balance of his opponents
because when he's drunk they their
balance is also affected so I think
that's what people we're talking about
in the manga I mean I'm gonna assume
that this person in just copy it that
it's just happened to be that like that
because I've also seen a lot of other
people who haven't read the manga submit
words that are similar to manga like
meteos quirk passing through objects but
they didn't know it so I'm gonna assume
that this isn't like a direct copy
spoilers minor character no one cares
Miriah oh no no but yeah Muriel has
words guys that he passes through
objects you
you learn he's introduced Knox [ __ ] oh
my god now the introduction will be so
lame
anyways never watched by here okay David
get all your fault watch it anymore next
matchup we have on us jean-jacques
okayed the paper hero page submitted by
shadow tag for a three versus synchro
submitted by gravity falls I don't know
I see synchro I think you you yell on us
spend her time really so it's a it's a
girl
um there the quark name is book burner
she spent her time reading due to her
being on I guess unpopular her father
attempted to get his family out of the
and poor and father attempt to get his
family out of the slums by taking a
large loan from loan sharks although he
when he couldn't repay them they ended
up getting burning his entire home to
the ground as Annius watched her books
burn in the flames she noticed monsters
and animals that she recognized from the
books emerged from the fire they only
they only lasted for five minutes before
they disappeared its nothingness but
this is when Anya's realized her true
quirk and she now aspires to be atop
euro so she can save lives and prevent
anyone from being subject to the
criminal underworld
basically her quirk is if the character
she can bring fictional characters to
life but only if she burns the book or
the material where they're contained and
for a limited time so there were quite a
few people who were like summon any
fictional character summon anyone and
will which will really Opie but I
thought this was cool because you can
you have to burn something it's only
temporary but still cool right and it
wouldn't be infinitely powerful
I don't know you burn a book you burn
the Bible there's comic books right in
my hero academia I think that's awesome
so like imagine you're in my hero
academia and then they're burning like a
one-piece thing and Zorro pops out with
his three swords yeah every jump does
those crossovers like that would be on
yeah that'd be amazing but at the same
time you have like your opponents
standing there trying to be all cool
when you pull Goku out of your ass and
then you know we have the second
character is syncro pull Saitama the
AIRC work is the quirk is techno jump
she can jump into any device that
includes electricity like computers
phones televisions and interact with it
what does that mean interact with it
basically she could manipulate I'm
guessing like a computer jump into a
computer at his cycle stop aah
she is a fun-loving girl who loves video
games and anime hey waifu what they're
all at all girl characters don't even
notice I just looked at like quirk and
character description even notice that
there was a lot of girl characters in
the actual bracket but sure you just
want the artist to draw a girl character
too bad drunken fist is woody at all
hell yeah
you guys gotta like a draw like a sumo
wrestler I got some like super fun
anyways and the artist roles as in draws
next canker quirk has a downside is even
though she can jump into electronic
devices a manipulator which is really
cool in the modern age if the device is
cut off from the source of electricity
like a blackout or the device is broken
or unplugged she will be trapped inside
until I'm tricity comes back so she can
be traveling in a device not good as a
child she uses it for like silly
purposes and virtual reality um as a
hero she can use it to quickly travel
with the help of her fast hero friends
to transport the phone that she's in and
she can attack enemies by pulling them
inside devices giving her the advantage
and she has extra phones in her suit
just in case
well she could pull other people into
apparently damn you could just go in
with a bunch of your friends and you get
emailed somewhere and then just pop out
you pull them into a video well 100 and
they're lovely why I'm like no you can't
the devices have to be in your vicinity
so as soon as you can't email herself
only in pellets she could potentially be
an on game console and like trap you not
game yo
pack forever yes and Briggs Banamex did
you get to Jo Jo port for yet not yet
I'm in like 24 part three get a move on
ready watch it all Boyd you remember a
red hot chili pepper Briggs a red hot
chili pepper red hot chili pepper the
electric guy that jumped into the phone
lines oh yeah
killed the dude that's basically this
mm-hmm yeah I'm magic it differently
kind of like he had like electrical
abilities too right yeah except aside
from the electrical abilities right so
imagine like how sick would it be if
this I'm assuming it's a girl because
adamak only picks girls but um of course
yeah but imagine like she walked into a
battlefield and like she said something
she's opens up open the / laptop drag
someone in that person gets dragged into
a video game there level one she plays
that game a lot cuz she's a nerd waifu
status and she's like a hundred and his
slice was a guy bo p thanks periodic
that'd be pretty cool or like they pull
each other to a street fighter game or
something like that yeah like like again
i feel like this character would be
really cool indiana right they're really
cool and what was the first one oh
bringing bringing stories to life yeah
eventually Opie well they're both
potentially Opie yeah they would have to
like bailed out to be limited in a way
that does make ridiculous but then again
one for all is also be like the air like
she's level 100 they're the presence of
a one fits kind of [ __ ] but they
would never do that could yeah I don't
know about that that's overkill like
your like your um your video anything
that the two o P is this lame it doesn't
actually work there we go
I thought that was a pretty good good
call another great video actually yeah
imagine they pull them into a street
fighter game and they had like rather
than because she's probably physically
weak right or Camp Street Fighter game
and then Ryu kicks his ass yeah yelling
you can create your own construct game
and then just like traveler they'll be
cool that'd be cool
well then you could keep her in a
pokeball the reason the reason I'm
paralyzed the reason I paired these two
of is because I thought
they were cool in their own different
ways well this one's a tough one
let's have some in Saitama but it's like
imagine has like paper Saitama sorting a
weaker version still one party but then
it's useless no but your code at one
punch the guy and I could but like I'm
at least okay
slightly weaker right there looking a
weaker version of them it can't be like
a hundred percent true thought it'd be
too much right also I mean I guess she
could summon like a dragon and then fly
on the dragon mm-hmm that'd be cool yeah
I like both but the nerd electronics
nerd inside me wants to go for a synchro
yeah you know it this is the who would
be a better waifu and it's synchro oh
yeah synchro all the way all right
synchro thank me there we go that's
criteria it is best girl waifu status
and it be it be injured an interesting
concept of scheme battle well I mean
both of these are so interesting so it
isn't a paper hero that's a single with
synchro but pops the paper here oh
that's a sick sick like Opie power
that's still limited to a way to make it
to make it interesting and then she
awakens or cork and can turn her
surroundings into paper okay it's not a
Paramecium alright non-canonical logia
there's a non-clinical okay that's paper
anyway we have twin twins so two
characters hito me and rikiya Nana Carta
aka puppeteer and puppet submitted by
zip-tie Cole blue and Pat which is like
a pate which was like a group effort the
group submission um so we have he to me
who can guide her brother's body
telepathically as if he it was her own
so she uses him like a puppet but it
doesn't work on anyone else
her brother his body is extremely
durable and can withstand an absurd
amount of damage and dish out just as
much but he needs to be controlled by
his sister she her body's very weak but
he's kind of dumb basically and can take
care himself so together they're a good
team but
without each other they're like they
both have some of your weaknesses ah
they depend on each other for everything
um pretty solid yeah it's that's
interesting good ready for example the
brother might come on like a crazy
rampage of his sister's not there to
take care of him like but he would never
hurt his it's like Hansel and Gretel
except not like Hansel and Gretel he's a
gentle giant character but like a
dangerous gentle drag energy like a Hulk
sort of so not gentle he's not a gentle
just like a gentle giant but not gentle
that was like my Hansel and Gretel thing
okay I guess he doesn't mean bad but
he's very dangerous because of his power
so the sister had seemed hungry without
him
she is very frail about without her he
just goes berserk so it's like a team
that's pretty powerful not in the Hulk
but smart yeah dad that's what that
combo is I like it cuz it's also not
Opie cuz at the same time you take out
Gretel Hansel's useless true true so
yeah you gotta they gotta work together
and I apologize for renaming your
characters but you're welcome anyways
the second one is submitted by its I'll
emerge the name is Alice by a my RJ
underscore 0 3 and the quirks name is
illusory link and with a kiss on the
cheek for example she can create a
connection with her opponents and see
their past memories after that she could
create on herself an illusion that
appears like an important person to them
so she makes herself looks like someone
important to them too in their mind and
that act and that's like linked to did
the memories it lasts for 15 minutes she
can use it with two people but she can't
at a time
I guess she needs physical contact and
if she uses it on too many people she
loses consciousness and she can't and
then she she can't turn off the power so
she gives us some
even if she doesn't want it around the
power the link is established yeah
backstory is she doesn't remember her
father because he I guess I assumed he
abandoned her so she began to hate her
father and for this reason she doesn't
reveal her last name so she keeps her
last thing hidden but a part of her
still looks for him and she also knows
that he tried to become a hero so she
decides to come on you know to to make
her father like actually come in and
seek her out and she hopes of becoming a
hero will have helped her clarify her
doubts about me and her father so daddy
issues and quirk with kissing mmm quirk
with kissing is good but uh Hansel and
Gretel I think are a better hello I find
it - some more original and more useful
power whereas like Alice is good but at
the same time it's only useful in one
way like once you see your stick once
you're never gonna see it again
I mean she does her kiss thing and she
goes into their memories but how many
times is that interesting so by your
criteria someone you want to see in the
show I would rather see Hansel and
Gretel I think I agree so one thing I
want to clarify though with the other
girl won't you kisses someone it's
automatic and then they picture someone
they they picture someone called dear to
them was that what you said yes so what
I think happens is she automatically
sees their memories and then an illusion
begins to project and she has to
concentrate really hard if she wants to
control the illusion mmm so the reason I
like that I want to defend
Alice as an anime character is I really
like the idea of not being able to turn
it off because that creates for a lot of
awkward especially in high school
situations like she likes a guy she
kisses him he starts freaking out look
you're my mother or something before you
go further uh start to feel donated five
dollars and he's a friend of mine so I'm
gonna shout him out he says hey just
restarted the stream shout out for when
I catch up so shout out to you man
actually my Chad is also extreme like I
don't even see that so I apologize guys
so my John is chad is like backwards
yeah it's what about now sorry but I do
see the lot of people talking into
chatting so mark has
so yeah thank you guys for that very
cool debate so far so okay yeah so your
vote Knox is for the twins Hansel and
Gretel all the way he Tommy and Rukia
Nino cotta ake a puppeteer and puppet I
like that more than your hands on you at
all yeah but what do you like better
Hansel and Gretel or Tito me and Ricky I
mean ekata
I mean I think you added some syllables
there I'm gonna go with Hansel Gretel
there we go Thanks oh yeah that is a
good choice I mean like that combo but
also respect to Alice I think that would
be a clue you mentioned I think it would
be though Hansel in the duo was also
like a cactus
yeah holla yes would it be though if
like it's worth it for one scene the
other characters worth like she kisses
someone in class one day and they start
picturing it another girl or their
mother or something like that another
girl
oh but okay why do we guys how about you
smash that like button on the stream so
that when I see a spike in likes I can
actually know how lags the chat is for
me thanks anyway so as you were saying I
saw on Nick Co posted cactus I don't
know they were posting characters the
whole stream and I'm exorbitant ly proud
of them they're awesome
anyway okay so the last matchup is
between yucca in submitted by at busy
for 5:06 and armory submitted by Logan a
K at abolished Shadow Ball as shadows
cool but basically yen quark is human hi
the ability to control bees and she grew
up in a family of heroes and was always
beat down because of her cleric that was
thought to do nothing but make beef
smooth until she turned 17 and did her
reassessment and they found that she
could control bees to attack carry her
and they correspond to her emotions hey
did you see that spiking likes hold up
by 50 no it didn't ya did it was 190 now
it's 240 240
three damn okay so okay now I see it
okay thank you guys
that's dummy the love hey you could
unlike no no but okay so that's cool
like you Madden remembered the mosquito
girl from one punch man like episode 1
episode 2 but yes - yes - when she's
like controlling all the mosquitoes and
flying with them and stuff this reminded
me of down like the bees can carry her
they listen to her they attack with her
they were except she herself is is is
very weak
unlike mosquito girl and yes yes so she
would be a normal girl but she control
bees and also however it could control a
create problems because they correspond
to her emotion so she's like angry or
upset or something they might start
getting angry even though she doesn't
want them to so I thought that was cool
as well and armory is let me get him
over here armory
his quirk is metal mold manipulate
metals into various shapes and he has a
glass he his father owns a dojo and he
grew up training alongside other
students in the use of hundreds of
different weapons swords knives staffs
chains throwing weapons etc he carries
multiple steel rods with him that he
turns into whatever weapon or armor he
needs in combat so he can't generate
steel but if he has various weapons with
him he can make them very versatile so
he could make machine guns and he's also
trained in martial arts because he grew
up in a dojo so that's very cool I like
both of them but I have to say I've owed
for armory okay I I would say my reasons
but I would rather not I'll go for fee
girl
I went from be girl as well I guess I
should have said my reasons fibers and
reasons then I guess so it's over now
alright be girl wins but armory would
definitely be a cool hearing again not
Opie because you have to carry this
stuff with you but that's why I like our
it's really cool yeah but I also like
the bee stuff because we stuff was done
before I mean we've seen it Naruto all
the Obamas did the same thing all of
them did that bro flying with a bunch of
bees is cool I don't care wait okay but
again all of 16 of these are amazing
there were many more than we couldn't
clue they were amazing alright so we're
finally in the second round in which we
have darkhero nightshade versus Santa
all Munim we're gonna have to remind me
what they do yeah I remember darkhero
nightshade but sad - you mean that's
just like a Japanese name yeah so Mimi
oh let me find her yeah breathe it I
remember shadow bimbo how can I forget
well yes uh shadow is horse jumping into
a shadow becoming a shadow moving like a
shadow and me onin is the objects
turning this changing the state oh and
liquid water oh and you said it's also a
whamon correct both are women I think
whamon who am in for the price of one
alright so shadow beemo versus state
girl United States of smash and again
nightshade submitted by @kk - jingle
Saltillo submitted by at min senpai I
don't know I wanna vote for here this is
so hard
I personally I leaning heavily so I will
vote for sauting immune on because I
really love that I was able to translate
it from the French and also that the
backstory right like Baxter where she
discovers her quirk saving her sister
from a fire she gets burned in the
process decides to oh I can be actually
helpful as a hero really cool quirk also
she's like a very character cool
character she wants to have her own like
God likes to wear colorful clothes wants
to have her own brand of clothing so I
feel like there's a lot going on with
salt oil
I don't know I have to say that this is
why I'm conflicted
I believe Satoru minyan is a cooler
quark however darkhero nightshade sounds
like better waifu material why because
she could jump into shadows okay
only Knox would say something like this
but okay because I'm trying to imagine
each character and the girl that would
jump into shadows is better waifu
material than stage girl who's wearing
hats and glasses all the time doing
chemistry chemistry girl I am like I'll
never follow my mind all right so we
have one vote for [ __ ] or nightshade
from I didn't say I vote for I just said
I like she's better waifu but the other
one is better quick okay so it would be
so both so awesome to see in battle-ax
I'm like I want them I want them in the
series because because remember a shadow
is just like the absence of light so our
girl song could not affect the shadow
right no shadows not a state of manner
yeah oh whoa whoa whoa you said she
could do to any non-organic life right
stay a girl oh thank goodness
I've been scary turns to mush no but the
thing is that the shadow would still be
a uneffective quark against Satya squirt
this isn't a fight yeah I know I know
I'm just saying in a hypothetical fight
it would be cool yeah shadow girl is
better waifu easily there's not always
an abundant amount of shadows around you
know yeah well she has her own shadow
yeah but in the darkness if it's pitch
dark no one can see anyway if there's
any amount of light then there is shadow
okay but her tits say say it's it's like
her shadow someone else's shadow and
like tiny shadows around I feel like it
wouldn't be as depending on where she is
and like the time of day it makes a huge
difference
well change dates any time
what if she's like esken or more
powerful when there's stronger light I
don't
doesn't say that in there right and no
one is like a scan or please how dare
you he stands above them all he's there
they are plentiful as grains of sand and
that's Kings he's talking about and I
only know that because I watched your
latest video Briggs yeah which you
should do more of both under latest
video again Oh are we first I vote for
saute on my girl that do you is state
girl state girl or a shadow bimbo please
look also waifu hmm
Briggs I want to have you vote first why
you guys okay fine so I vote shadow
bimbo what do you have to say now
exactly so many time this dream I agreed
with the first person and then it's over
and the third person doesn't matter
their vote I did that to Hannah back so
many times I'm like come on you gotta
have some I knew you were gonna vote for
shadow girl so I had to go last
I see I just want to see your girl stay
girl running around with a water gun
that we pretty dope [ __ ] a hose oh man
so are you are you voting for my girl
saw - yes yes - one shot - um you know
in the night I'm not upset it's a better
quirk it's just a worse waifu the next
fight the next set up is a boy lotto vs
Jack Hennessy but keep in mind that some
people get triggered the Genesee has a
quirk very similar to someone in the
[ __ ] that's a plus in my book
[Music]
there's so much did there so well done
guys
now these are amazing thank thank you
I'm gonna take the compliment for
picking these amazing entries out of a
thousand entries many of which were
really really good hmm
this is possibly gets added back for the
next five minutes competition coming
next enter your greatest sound effect
and we will pick the 16 top sound
effects again lotto is the comic relief
hilarious character jacket is he also a
comic relief hilarious carry this sound
effect work could create any sound a be
pretty sick copy anyone's voice sonic
screeching thing that'd be cool that
would be cool but that's not here um I
should have entered god damnit I was
considering it but I knew he wouldn't
have picked it yeah the judges you can't
enter but we will have more of these
comments in the future like I know some
people the chatter site we should do
another one definitely going to do it
because I didn't expect such a huge
response guys and so many entries so
because you guys cared so much there
were so many creative entries we'll
definitely a more contests like this
maybe once a month or something we'll
see but definitely very cool oh you're
gonna be cheesed on the next contest we
do I'm gonna create a separate account
enter by the way physiognomy hall say
sad I didn't get in but I enjoyed
creating the art thank you for entering
the contest if you did or I don't know
if you're saying that you didn't get in
a on the right time but either way thank
you everyone for contributing okay I
vote lotto I think work is really cool
but at the same time he needs to be
drunk to make the other guy drunk and
he's 1500 it's like he wants to be a
hero
he ain't becoming a hero if he was like
a vigilante because they wouldn't accept
him into hero academy that would be sick
just running around with like bottles of
vodka straps his belt I'm looking for
Jack I like law my leaving it off to me
so like I feel like the potential just
to animate some like fights with someone
who's like super drunk is amazing like
watching someone drunken fist is the
best thing ever for me yeah adam ak is
an ante to pioneer by Tosun king thank
you sir I don't know what that means but
let's be true
I so is your world for Jack a hundred
percent oh this is tough because a lot
of so many funny situations I think
lotto would be a guy character well this
guy can be yeah so trying to be right
now toss him aside character but he does
the drunken fist style like Jackie Chan
I think I actually changed my boat if
you don't mind hand change to Jack
Hennessy because I just thought of a
situation that'll be incredible fine
okay so then my decision isn't deal but
Jack Hennessy wins this one you imagined
is getting drunk they drop him off a
helicopter intellect amongst like a ton
of villains and they'll Jackie and then
the support guys come in and take them
down yeah like from a distance obviously
or they'd get drunk
oh man that's so amazing it would be
funny though it's like if he's get he's
put into a fight where he's not drunk
so he's drinking during the battle and
slowly he's getting away he starts off
getting beaten and slowly the tables
turn I think that'd be an awesome fight
exactly I need my boat fine alcohol
pardon sorry I don't matter you're
talking over you I'm saying if you can't
find alcohol that's a weakness well he's
got to be like the guy from he's like
sugar guy he keeps it on him
yeah I don't know why I was gonna say
the guy from Mortal Kombat to kill you
has like a huge tub I think it's a huge
tub on his back okay so Jack moves on
into the next round
lotto we love you but Johnny next time
next matchup is almond vs. synchro so I
want the guy who by touching you can
make you terrify you and have you have
your worst fears anti-villain versus
synchro yeah yes someone uses it on
people who have done things to like as
punishment and synchro who can jump into
devices and bring people and so for
example video games and both could be
great interrogators because
can put someone into virtual reality and
portion of their or you can torture them
with their own traumatic memories and
stuff so yeah a lot of torturing I felt
like if I'm on is done well he could be
more interesting like for example if
he's fighting against heroes cuz heroes
take tried to take down anti-heroes and
if they try to take him down like let's
say imagine the stain fight but in
middle of the fight instead of licking
deck whose blood he grabs deck whose
head there's nothing and I could just
start shrieking falling to the ground
and pissing himself yes it would be
humiliating for deku but I don't really
care because I'm on sounds pretty badass
and while synchro does sound like waifu
I'm voting for Amon I think he's cool
like synchro is a waifu bro I'm gonna
leave this one to anima I'm buddy for
synchro I I feel like the potential here
is amazing me mad after like at the end
of the day the other person I think
there's one alternate like just one
thing that's gonna happen right like but
there's so many possibilities with
synchro true and I and like someone in
the chat mentioned that we'll dykes
mentioned that scarecrow from Batman has
a similar power to Amon so it's not like
it's completely original but I really
liked was the idea of synchro and like
combining virtual reality with real
reality especially in the modern world
where technology's everywhere the thing
is before you before you vote for
synchro because I don't mind if you do I
just want to get my thing about Amon
it's not like scarecrow I actually
thought of Scarecrow but the biggest
difference is scarecrow is a villain and
he's an antihero because this is a very
villain quirk yes
yep but he's a justice and I think it's
like the cool mansion I think every
fight could be completely different with
syncro yeah
like imagine one fight they're having
that they goes into a street fighter
game and then the next fight like he's
just like teleporting between like
different devices to get behind an
opponent to like attack of them yeah
Joe's mirror guy going to say you know
the mirror Guyana Mac yes I do I was
crazy overpowered yeah a lot of them are
crisply did justice stand like dear Lord
which is justice again the mist that it
can control people like puppets
including Onassis Oh
yeah that was amazing Oh like the fact
they beat some of these is just so far I
think the most overpowered one that no
one talks about is the nightmare guy
which ones that the guy that goes into
your dreams and kills you in your dreams
I haven't gone there yet oh yeah it's in
the first part of Joe Joe's part 3 hmm
it's at the end closer to the end it's
the baby spoilers no no I don't think
I'm very okay never mind but it was
amazing it's definitely in the first
part okay yeah I'm voting for synchro
because of the potential but again I'm
one very cool character but synchros
quirk is just think of it this way who
would you like to see drawn I'm on would
be a big thing grow ah what does he sing
crow - yeah okay sacrum moves on to the
next round you would respect - by the
way the next round is the semi-finals
soul synchro is now in the semi-finals
the final matchup Florida semi-finals
and so I Gretel the twins puppeteer and
puppet versus Yaka yen boys he's a guy
in again moment it was the big who's the
girl with to be yes the controlling of
the bees I went with hands on better the
bees and I vote for Hansel and Gretel
because I call them an office here at
Bachman is cooler it's cooler whoa
I mean I guess I I'm kind of conflicted
I love both of these but the twins win
so they move on to the semi-finals
yeah the b1 is quite or ISA I KN and so
now in the semi-finals we have sat - you
mean on the changing of different estate
a matter versus Jack Hannah see the
alcohol guy and in the other semi-finals
we have synchro versus the twins oh man
this is tough now this is tough
I vote for so frenzied Jack Hennessy
versus all - you mean on husband oh no I
think that as cool as this
Corgan Larry as it as it is thanks funny
to you as a character is more complete
and think about it this way
Jack it's gonna be funny the first few
episodes like he's in the show right but
eventually it's like oh yeah he's drunk
we get it
whereas with Santoshi her core can keep
changing to different situations
maybe so you're selling that they're
both main characters I'm not no but like
what I'm saying is imagine imagine
imagine imagine the different
possibilities in a fight in my control
Joe type fight even with Santos quirk
changing there is no comparison from
here academia to JoJo's fights
I feel like Satya would could be in a
jojo's fight because of her perky so
complex no comment
you have to finish JoJo's man um I'm
going for Jack - sorry Adam I know I
know you're saying like you might like
you're saying like I'm not I'm not even
voting from for the funny aspect I think
it'd be awesome to see ok zing yo
imagine this guy ok he's not one of the
typical main character guys he's one of
the pro heroes for example you know how
often we see all jeans we don't see him
all that much but whenever you see him
your heart is pumping with exhilaration
cuz you know he's the greatest thing
you've ever laid my eyes on so so was
this guy he's or he's one of the
teachers do you imagine is one of the
teachers yeah amazing how I still think
that Satya was an awesome character so I
would definitely about respect man John
Hennessy Scolari's submitted by Jason
Zod and Softail was submitted by MIM
senpai so to own two to one on this one
and soul Jack had a seat is in the
finals next second semi-final match up
is synchro versus Hansel and Gretel
yearbook man this is a tough one though
this is a really hard one
god help me out here because this is
thought I say we leave it off the Anna
Mac well I don't mind starting cuz I
already know what I want I know I think
synchro is better waifu much more
original quick and a far more a more
rounded li written character on the
other hand Hansel and Gretel are called
Hansel and Gretel
I love I would love to call them Hansel
and Gretel in the finals and therefore I
vote for synchro I didn't see that one
coming that's not enough of a reason to
vote for them
rest in peace Hansel and Gretel rest him
oh okay I thought you're gonna give a
reasonable thing yeah I thought you were
studying up for some Hansel and Gretel's
nice by the way Klaus donated $10 thank
you - say precision speech would be a
cool quirk where you can talk to anyone
anywhere in volume I'm actually speaking
it it's pretty sick so so like I'm
guessing like miles away you can talk to
someone just then again it's the same
idea is the telepathic they can't lady
yeah telepods but people can't speak
back to them so it might be that but he
also adds Death Note rules so yeah a
Death Note quick who you going for adam
ak I don't know we have a we have it's
interesting
synchros a waifu also let's not forget
why the power metal in the child we have
synchro twins we see we see a lot of
interesting comments yo why not I see
any Hansel and Gretel in the chat
because their puppeteer and puppet they
are not alright let's take a vote
puppeteer and puppet or Hansel and
Gretel there we go Oh Thank You Chet you
don't get to change the characters names
Rockstar who oh no say that's to quit
crazy little bobble 500 I don't know if
the atom I voted yet but I haven't yet I
don't know mm-hmm it's not really that
hard to choose right now let's see
what's the girl's name that's best girl
singer I'm looking for synchro so yeah
no I think see girls a great character
great power especially like I said in
the modern world without all of us being
nerds beep on a device right now
streaming live right so it's great but
definitely like the twins but I want to
see here drama I love the idea that it's
like together they're overpowered but if
you can separate them you know they're
weeks or like they're easy like Mossi
menos from Teen Titans
mm-hmm okay so the finals is gonna be
checking to see where's the syncro but
before we do that we will talk about the
top the top three meme entries that I
like see which meme and she wins at all
number one was next cactus yes mr. nice
man at mr. nice man underscore zero zero
submitted knocks knocks Taku hero named
cactus quirk back story do you really
need one and he submitted a drawing on
back stock was and that was a beautiful
one we in case you don't know some
context in the last rant cafe on my
channel we were talking about the best
world to live in and one of the parts of
the debate was going on hero academia
and I said why do you want to live in
here academia you're born with a random
quirk yes you could shoot explosions yes
it could be a make you super strong but
you could be born looking like a cactus
and so this all began yes and then move
like his penis it would be terrible for
masturbation your girlfriend would hate
it it was great it was a great describe
trust me someone out there would love it
well rock girl or something out anyways
my Lords Wiegel @ LT w YT o hero name
name I Neymar jr. quark diamond roll
back story after being targeted by
villains Neymar jr. discovered his quark
diamond role this quirk allows him to
fall down as though it seems as he is
hit although he isn't after falling down
he can roll away to it basic only Lord
we go would come up with something like
that yes and finally we have submitted
by h sk @ yeah boy HS k name Dio Brando
quirk the world my world oh well it says
the world okay
now was the time stopping time stopping
and punching a ghost and then it says
backstory you were expecting a backstory
but it was me deal
goddammit so hard with the shoes three
I'm still going with Knux cactus
just because I'm slightly biased towards
that one
but then again Lord Twigg oh and Lord
Dio hmm I'm gonna go with the Neymar jr.
just because I love the World Cup and I
hated Neymar's and think so
and of course apparently Lord we go is
the ultimate [ __ ] anime character
Knox yes something incredible that I
have to say if you go to like any seven
deadly sins clip on YouTube the top
comments are our Lord tweet people that
don't know about your channel probably
so frustrated it might have more
difficult than I got when I made the top
10 puff n uh commandments list but it
was really large like oh yeah any of the
Lord tweet go clips have so many views
but we also have M king in the chat
saying you thought this was a meme but
it was me deal yeah so yeah so we have
one with Neymar okay so we have one
float for cactus knocks - old Mark jr.
so the name are doing your Kirk wins
lords we go
you get glory no primary tool or
tweaked-out glory praise the stache oh
wow
Bray sister what is Lord twiggles uh all
name like son for all what is his name
he is too great to just be all yeah it's
not stache for all he's more than all
alright back to the real tournament the
finals is John Hennessy drunk guy versus
synchro and I think that synchro is
waifu and the better character like i
said jack is really cool and funny but I
feel like after a while the court kind
of gets you know you get you get it he's
drunk he monkey fight lights but synchro
is like any it's like so versatile
getting
gets it to any device can create fantasy
worlds we are like a lot of possible and
synchro could also be you know lightful
teacher couldn't use it to teach people
in my commercial battlefield and stuff
that'd be cool so yeah my vote for
synchro I think I would rather see
synchro be drawn because I think the
same thing I hope I think I like
Hennessy better but I would rather see
synchro drawn some drunk guy if Jack was
really good trouble you do some long
hair a big bottle on his back or like a
big bottle like with them type of thing
you know we're gonna pay for the odd art
pay the artists and we're gonna get
Rockley there you go step from the anime
I vote synchro sorry I think synchros
quark is pretty sick also I hate
pictures synchro being drawn like which
I monitor like a GAD okay don't feel
like coming out of a computer I don't
know I can't picture her speeding so
cute yeah hmm
agreement are we in yet unanimous on
sacral I think I'm biased and want Jack
just to see him fight I like to add one
I want to see drunken fist be like [ __ ]
tougher words I could talk but anyway
I'm gonna go for synchro I think it's
more potential with her character and
she's probably a cuter okay so unanimous
probably falls congratulations by the
way all 16 of these euros like I said
we're in the top 2% or something of all
submissions they are all awesome and I
would love to see all of them in the
anime or in the manga or whatever I
think they're all awesome but synchro
one wins and also cool name and synchro
that's cooling oh that this was cool
this was fun what do you guys think chat
was this fun that is you know resounding
applause in the chat
that's lagging cataloger chug
they're like they're like but this after
you're me you know guys yeah
but noise yeah this was really fun like
I said so many awesome submissions and
so much creativity so definitely thanks
to each and every one of you who
submitted and we will definitely have
more contests in the future for MHA and
other anime because we received such a
response from you guys if we had it
would have been a one-time thing well
because it was such a huge response I'm
definitely down through this maybe even
once a month if we can make that happen
and if you want to see what this
character is gonna look like cuz she is
gonna be hella waifu artist is pretty
sick link to all of our Twitter's in the
description correct yes so follow really
but it'll figure it out and Instagram
and stuff that it will be announced
there and also in some boku no hero
video I will also once the drawing is
made I will we will post it to show
everyone and I'm also going to contact
the winner through this core because I
believe they submit it through discord
but yeah really cool and it's nothing
gonna happen in the future and I can
definitely give you guys a list of the
top 16 finalists I can post that
somewhere we didn't make up an actual
bracket because we don't have any
pictures usually we make up the brackets
with pictures but within this case you
know for most of them we can how many
pictures so we just kind of did I guess
you could you could improvise like for
Medusa put a snake and for do so we do
introvert know for most of them we don't
yeah I'll draw them next time don't
worry I got ya ready my six figures oh
yeah listen so salt so Spacey mix bass
face says increased word count you want
to read a thousand submissions with more
than 200 words each think about it a
thousand submissions think about it this
way it's a good thing we have anime yeah
I wasn't reading that yeah we're all
illiterate here I can barely speak oh
yeah thank you everyone for joining us
this was really fun the winner is again
synchro submitted by gravity fall
all awesome entries we got so many great
entries and we will do this again in the
future so follow on Twitter Instagram
that kind of stuff in order to be
notified when we do it trust me you will
not be notified on YouTube because
especially lately notifications have not
been going out but social media is
usually better to follow all of us and
if their social media is not in the
description if you go to the an amount
for Twitter and I'm a pro I tagged them
in the polls talking about this so Knox
and old anime will be there anything
else you guys want to say before we wrap
it up stay weird fam more than all more
than older otherwise known as Lord we go
guys
this was a fun stream guys participated
everyone participated special thanks to
Anna Mack who actually really put a lot
of time into this one yeah by the way if
you guys are wondering I read all of
them like all the ones on Twitter
Instagram this I went through all of
those it's a lot of people were like can
you respond to tell me that I you got it
I can't respond to all every one of them
but I definitely did read all unless you
like deleted it before I read it but as
long as it's not deleted it's there I
read it so yeah
thanks again everybody such a pleasure
as always right to face every week at 5
p.m. Eastern Standard Time on Thursdays
leave a like if you like this channel or
my channel either this shuttle or NOx
luckless channel and more contests are
to come so stay tuned and until next
time see ya space cowboys bang I'm
actually gonna have to like press the
buttons yeah say thank God called the
anime cringy outro for 10 times in one
video yay woo